Donald Trump is chickening out, uh, recognizing
the Armenian genocide as a genocide.
Right after a threat from Turkish president
Erdogan, the Senate recently passed a bipartisan
measure to recognize the Armenian genocide
for what it is.
It was a genocide and uh, this was passed
as a foreign policy position.
It was a rare bipartisan bill.
The 1915 killings were 1.5 million Armenians
were killed by the Ottoman empire was a genocide
and that's what the Senate said and that's
what they intended to recognize.
President Erdogan then came in and issued
a threat saying, if you do that, Turkey will
recognize the killing of native Americans
in retaliation.
We'll talk about that later.
And Trump has had the state department reject
the measure from the Senate saying that no
matter what the Senate says, the position
of the United States on this issue is not
going to change.
Saying, quote, this has spokesperson Morgan
Ord haggis in a statement to the Hill.
The position of the administration has not
changed.
Our views are reflected in the president's
definitive statement from April.
Now, if you go back to April on April 24 that
was global Armenian remembrance day.
Trump said that 1.5 million Armenians were
quote, deported, massacred, or marched to
their deaths.
And when you say that anyone who understands
the nuances of the Armenian genocide understands,
you are not saying 1.5 million were killed
and therefore you are not recognizing it as
a genocide.
When you say 1.5 million were deported, massacred,
or marched to their deaths, you could be suggesting
that of the one point 5000001.49 9 million
were merely deported.
Right?
And that is why anyone who understands this
issue understands that you've really got to
look at the letter of what is being said to
hear to understand it.
Now, let's be totally transparent here and
thorough.
It's not just Trump that won't simply say
the Armenian genocide was a genocide.
For example, when Barack Obama was a candidate
back in 2008 he said it was a genocide.
And then when he became president, the administration
did not support a resolution which said that
it was a genocide.
So this is a far bigger issue than just Donald
Trump, of course.
Now, as far as the Turkish threat to recognize
the genocide by European settlers in the United
States against native Americans, that really
shouldn't scare anyone.
I mean, it is our history.
It's what happened.
Many countries have a very ugly history.
Look at, I was born in Argentina.
A lot of people say, David, why are there
no black people in Argentina?
Uh, it's a, it's ugly, right?
I mean, that's the reality and we can't ignore
history.
We know historically why there are no black
people in Argentina.
We know what happened here in the United States.
The idea that people might not know that is
disheartening, but it unfortunately may be
a reality in some circles.
And meanwhile, you have Donald Trump calling
Elizabeth Warren Pocahontas regularly.
We hear in Donald Trump are talking about
the weakest self-professed strong man that
we have maybe ever seen.
He's a genius, but we can't see his grades.
And he'll Sue you if you release them.
He's super rich, but we can't see his taxes.
And he will hire lawyer upon lawyer upon lawyer
to make sure that you don't see his taxes.
He makes great deals, but he gets bamboozled
by North Korea into thinking that he made
a deal when in fact he got nothing and on
and on and on.
Most of the details you've probably heard
by now, but the big picture once again is
that this guy professes to be one thing and
falls embarrassingly short of that.
And it's happening once again here with him
being strong on foreign policy and American
sovereignty, which anyone who's been paying
attention would not be surprised by.
But to some of his most ardent supporters,
they see this and it's the cognitive dissonance
of your dog when they hear your voice come
out of a, uh, of a speaker, they see a little
bit of confusion.
Uh, and a disorientation I think is the way
I would describe it.
Let's take a quick break.
I do want to talk about this totally fake
staged interview that Ivanka Trump gave
and we've got to talk about the Afghanistan
papers.
Major, major story, both of those and your
voicemail coming up after the break